yeah the happiest people I knew in
University were the guys who couldn't
today yeah I remember because I used to
I used to be an RA so I used to manage a
thousand students
um and that's why I learned a lot of
this stuff because people talk about the
stuff they think I'm manipulative no I
just know women in it I've actually been
out here like for like years in it
um and one of the guys he's like I think
he's like um an actuary and his friend
to the happiest human beings I ever met
I walked in there just chilling making
love for each other they used to go gym
do all this stuff but I never heard them
discuss me when they weren't dating
anyone they didn't give a flying [ __ ] he
still hasn't purchased anything happiest
people the people I know who sleep
around men as well because hypogamy does
make a lot of men happy uh you know
they're constantly in that drama phase
they're constantly like yeah I agree
it's not it's not a happy place which is
why everyone should have a roster
same thing
sorry isn't a roster the same thing
but as in Shallow relationships with
multiple people so you're just running
through them as I said I don't run
through people like like the rust they
are actually valid people I just don't
want to settle down so why would I build
a really intense relationship with one
person but see that's you I think and
there may be obviously a percentage of
men that do that and that's that's fine
but you also have other percentage of
men like if we broke it down to a pie
chart you have to amend that out here
just having sex for ego and just to be
validated you have the men that are
doing it because they don't want a
relationship but they want some company
and that's fine they're not really
trying to hurt anyone out here but
they're not trying to sit down cool then
you have the men that actually want to
get married have like an actual life
with a woman then you have the men that
are actually damaged because they've
been they've been with women that are
damaged now they have damage and they
don't end up getting with anyone because
they're no they get the most from girls
actually the damage but you know what
happens with them the 34 Euros the 50
euros the six year olds that stay single
but have to keep dating young girls
because older women
she don't want you no actually it's
easier to get older woman
I think no I'm saying he'll date younger
women because the old woman at some
point an older woman should either
settle or she'll be like I can't be
bothered to put up with this there's two
types of women they'll say oh they won't
but I'll put up with what put up with
someone who for example is too stubborn
doesn't care about their feelings don't
want to give them attention well that's
just because she's shooting out of her
league if like that's the way the guy
treats you she doesn't like you you're
just I'm saying you're sharing that
toxic place after they've not
transitioned like
if it's high value though
different types of women I'm just
talking about different types of men and
I'm saying that's fine because you're in
a different place but I'm saying if
we're looking at percentage of men in
general you have these different types
of men just like how you have these
different types of women like there's no
general for anyone let's be honest you
know why like those damaged men do the
best in the Dayton Market yeah because
they know how to play the game because
they're gonna flip in between Alpha and
beta because it could have been like the
tough guy but they also have deep
emotional needs so they'll try and
connect with these women emotionally
they'll flip between those women they're
not like you though you're saying that
you don't connect with them on that
level because you understand you're
emotional let's say boundaries to keep
yourself away from that because you
don't want that but some men they might
be like oh yeah I want this actually
freak out it's the same with women
that's what I'm saying like the pie
chart is there if if a woman's freaking
out in the quoting stage you're doing
something wrong you're going away
because every single woman I date
generally if they're good intelligent
woman most women want a long-term
relationship if they're not with you
then you're missing something and you
know you're probably giving way too much
attention and validation probably needy
there's something there because the
longer you spend with a woman the more
she's gonna like you in it women are
like that when she's committed to
spending time with you she's not I'm not
speaking for America you guys are crazy
I don't know what's going on over there
London is not better I know of many
America yeah yeah I forget I'm in London
sometimes because it's so Americanized
well way behind we're 10 years behind
you guys I think we're getting there but
I see videos of women being like Oh I do
this and I leave I like I sleep with men
and I ghost them it's like what
you've seen some of the Vlog the blog
Pages here you guys got wild [ __ ] on
those too
but yeah so they're good at flipping
with that but um but that's the
transition period there's a transitional
period of Life sorry in other words
they've got game yeah
because it's kind of thing these guys
also I I I'm gonna sell this once and
four right this idea that sleeping with
loads of women means you're like a top
guy it doesn't it just means exactly
most of the time it means you're a loser
it means you don't you don't have any
goals why do you need an ego stroke
you're not you're not pushing for
anything you have way too much time to
spend you know uh putting like 20 women
in the talking stage and then dealing
with all their games until you fight
they finally sleep with you it normally
means high value men are selective not
just anyone can walk into my life I
agree exactly usually usually they are
making up for an insecurity or they're
trying to feed the ego normally they
spent too much time in a long-term
relationship in like their early 20s and
then she left and then they're trying to
make up now they want to date all this
is also debatable they get a lot of
attention now that's normally what I see
the guys who are sleeping with being
promiscuous past like 25 to like in
their 40s they dated one girl for like
seven years when they were like 18 and
then she left and then they think [ __ ] I
could have slept with all these hotties
and now now they just want to stay with
us that's why they say that like men
with more sexual partners are like
happier in their relationship cannot you
cannot just say exactly what you just
said so man so when men okay the
happiest relationships are when like
they're both virgins like that's number
one but it's like if a man slept with
around I don't remember exactly what it
was but it was roughly like three
Partners versus eight or nine Partners
he's happily he's happier in his
relationship when he's had eight or nine
yeah I I tested out I think men this has
just been my experience the more women
I've slept with the more I've worked out
what it is I want what I don't want it's
essentially it's unintentionally been a
screening process of weeding out the
weak type of process yeah and now it's
and now it's essentially it left me in a
position where I knew exactly what I
wanted what was completely
non-negotiable
and I would shoot for that I would be
very selective and that's made me very
happy now you have to screen guys like
there's no a lot of guys are frustrated
right now and you know I see it in the
comments because a lot of guys you give
way too much time and attention to women
who have nothing to offer back and they
get frustrated and as a guy who's been
way past that stage I'll tell you most
of these people aren't they don't care
about you they don't like you the
average woman so you've got a screen too
oh yeah a lot of guys looked at that
that stage and were like you know like I
think I just talked to anyone on the
road Nabi I have to kind of like and
respect you first like that's just a
stage and the ignoring bit is when I
have conversations I say things and try
and inquire but if someone doesn't give
me a good enough response if it's not
like if I ask her more than three
questions and she doesn't ask me
anything back I just stop replying right
like I'll just read you know I I have a
super chat real quick it says people
wanting real solutions this is a
conversation about healing seeing
acupuncturist or a tantric yoga expert
so on the damage is not permanent
there's no perfect solution but if you
don't mind it don't matter commit to
what matters okay go ahead I have a
question for the fellas do you think
that the more sexual partners a guy has
been with the harder it is for him to
accept one woman for the rest of his
life no
no no I think well actually I don't want
to generalize here I'm going to say
specifically from my from my position no
I think getting loads out of my system
when I was younger has allowed me to be
far more selective know what I want and
what I don't want as and now has made me
very specific in who I want to go for
and as
I I am now in a happy long-term
relationship as a result and I attribute
a lot of that to essentially the quote
unquote weeding out process that I want
I think so the host can kind of be like
okay can I ask you a question yeah you
you helped pave the way for the [ __ ]
woman in the future as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible